mabrouk c'est le député christian jacob
président du parti des républicains
merci d'être avec nous ce matin sur
europe 1 christian jacob
agnès buzyn c'est une menace pour
rachida dati écoutez c'est d'abord une
solution par défaut avec bon une
candidate se dire on s'improvise pas
mais redonne un candidat à la mairie de
paris
dans ces conditions un mois avant
l'avant l'élection il ya quatre jours et
nous disait que la seule chose qui le
mobilise est c'était sans cette option
ministère d'ailleurs avec un bilan qui
n'est pas reluisant permettez-moi de le
dire quand on voit la situation dans
laquelle l hôpital public depuis qu'elle
est qu'elles arrivent et qui va de crise
en crise démission de chef de service
la réforme sur les retraites dont elle
avait la charge
franck tout le monde s'accorde à dire
que jamais une réforme n'était aussi mal
aussi mal conduite
et puis là elle est là pourquoi elle est
là pour répondre à la fébrilité pour ne
pas dire à la panique du président de la
république et liva le pistolet sur la
tempe guidon qui s'est pas une menace
qu'elle attaque envers elle est ce que
vous craignez qu'elle récupère des voix
de droite agnès buzyn ya pas de
prochaine ya pas de programme vous savez
nous on a on a une candidate
rachida dati qui fait une campagne
remarquable avec un vrai projet qui
répond aux attentes des parisiens sur la
sécurité sur le logement sur la mobilité
sur la propreté et regardons dans dans
quel état est aujourd'hui la ville de
paris est en face de cela
quel est le seul projet qui s'impose et
qui aujourd'hui mobilisée parisien ces
projets de rachida dati c'est pour ça
qu'elle a elle est passée de la de
gauche 12 % il y a trois quatre mois à
20 21% aujourd'hui parce que les
parisiens se reconnaissent dans son
projet elvi paris au coeur mais l'a fait
la démonstration de ce qu'elle était
capable de faire dans sa mairie
d'arrondissement
hélas cette expérience et puis alain
vrai projet elle a tout pour vous
néanmoins à la besoin aussi d'un soutien
de poids nicolas sarkozy va la soutenir
lors d'un meeting
il faut ses soutiens là aujourd'hui pour
faire basculer les arrondissements
faveur de rachida dati
à l'écouter il faut que la famille soit
rassemblée moi je le souhaitais d'elle
dès le départ et
s rachida dati le fait dans cet esprit
effet cette campagne encore une fois en
direction des parisiens mais il faut
aussi que tout le monde serre les rangs
et soit rassemblée et le fait que
nicolas sarkozy s'engage et apporte son
soutien à rachida dati s'est
effectivement aussi une très bonne
nouvelle rassemblement dites vous est ce
que c'est le cas justement de la droite
sur la réforme des retraites en examen à
l'assemblée qu'elle saint jacques à
quelles consignes d'ailleurs a été donné
aux députés aient l'air à ce qu'à
l'issue des débats tous doivent voter
comme un seul homme contre cette réforme
écoutez nous nous avons pris un choix
d'opposition différent de ce qui a été
pris par l'extrême gauche qui sont dans
une logique d'obstruction
on a fait le choix de la responsabilité
nous sommes un parti de gouvernement et
donc en partie gouvernement nous avons
présenté un contre-projet
ce qui est insupportable et
invraisemblable aujourd'hui sur la
manière dont ces débats sont sont
conduits et l'attitude du gouvernement
on parle d'une réforme des retraites
avec un budget de 300 milliards et on
explique au parlement écoutez circulez
ya rien à voir
vous voter ce texte on parlera du
financement plus tard et on a le
sentiment que c'est insupportable qui
est quinze jours de débats l'assemblée
avec tout ça à la fin vous avez voté
contre si je vous comprends bien écoutez
nous sommes de toute façon dans une
logique d'opposition clair pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que il
n'y a pas de financement
ensuite au delà du fait de ne pas de ne
pas avoir de financement on a tergiversé
sur l'âge de départ légal
nous nous considérons sur les retraites
c'est d'abord une réforme budgétaire
comment on trouve l'équilibré soit en
baisse les pensions c'est ce qu'a fait
ce gouvernement
avec l'augmentation de la csg soit on
augmente les cotisations de ceux qui
travaillent et en plombent leur pouvoir
d'achat
soit on est sur une mesure d'âge et nous
nous assumons clairement d'être dans une
mesure d'âge donc à partir de là on ne
votera pas cette réforme ne va pas même
si même s'ils créent saint-jacques ap le
texte amendé et même si ce n'est pas
exclu il ya un retour d'une mesure d'âge
vous ne voterez contre vous ne le dit
c'est écoutez si nos amendements
tremblay mais à un débat parlementaire
si nos amendements que ce matin vous
pouvez pas dire que vous votre économie
d'ailleurs lorsque j'étais pendant dix
ans près vingt neuf ans présidente
groupe jamais je n'ai pris une position
avant le débat simplement ce que je vous
dis aujourd'hui c'est que la réforme
telle qu'elle est présentée aujourd'hui
on ne la votera pas mais maintenant les
ne feriez pas dire que je suis du débat
si le texte est à manger si vous
imaginez que eux
la république en marche soit traversé
par un élan de bon sens et qu'il vienne
à soutenir nos propositions
à ce moment là effectivement si c'est
notre réforme
et si nos amendements passe
effectivement ne voterons du vent c'est
pour ça que nous voulons avoir ce débat
l'assemblée du monde
vous voulez avoir le débat justement est
ce que jean luc mélenchon l'empêchent ce
débat est ce que vous regrettez tout
cela pour la qualité des débats à
l'image du parlement l'extrême gauche
l'a fait les communistes l'ont fait
avant et sont souvent dense est dans
cette logique d'oxo d'obstruction ça
n'est pas la logique que nous avons
recul nous nous avons souhaité présenter
un contre-projet qui nous rassemble tous
d'ailleurs
il ya une unanimité des parlementaires
les républicains sénateurs comme comme
député pour présenter ce contre-projet
est donc nous allons y aller amendement
par amendement opposition par un vrai
débat de fond vous pourriez donc
comprendre qu'en dernier recours bien
sûr en dernier recours on utilise le
gouvernement utilise le 49-3 justement
pour mettre un terme à cette obstruction
ça veut dire qu'il est incapable sa
majorité en train d'exploser vous savez
quand on utilise de 49,3 c'est qu'on ne
tient pas sa majorité la majorité c'est
contre l'obstruction et de l'opposition
de la réalité c'est que parce que la
majorité est fébrile si la majorité
quand une majorité n'est pas fébrile on
n'utilise pas le 49-3 c'est un signe de
faiblesse mais mais on voit bien
l'affaiblissement de cette assise dans
la constitution
oui bien sûr non mais bien sûr mais bien
sûr en libye non non non mais je joue
je le reconnai volontier ceci étant ça
n'est pas un signe de solidité je sois
nous comme les autres gouvernements et
notamment ceux de gauche qui l'ont
souvent plus utilisé que nous c'est
d'ailleurs contre leur propre majorité
la crise est toujours là quand on
utilise le 49-3 c'est qu'on n'est pas
sûr que sa majorité
tout à l'heure en déplacement à mulhouse
emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer sur la
lutte contre le communautarisme ou
plutôt le séparatisme comme l'elysée
l'appel est ce que le sursaut de la part
du président est en marche
christian jacob tout d'abord c'est
n'importe quoi ce débat sémantique est
ce que le sujet aujourd'hui c'est de
philosopher sur le débat sémantique est
ce qu'on parle de ce m
depuis dix ans la droite dit qu'il faut
nommer les choses non mais il devait
nommer les choses c'est le
communautarisme
ça veut dire quoi ces paroles et les
séparatistes non non non est-ce que ce
dont on a besoin aujourd'hui c'est une
vraie politique de sécurité de lutte et
se renforce contre cc-150 quartiers qui
sont aux mains de l'islam politique de
radicaux de dangereux extrémistes et en
attend une politique de sécurité
on n'attend pas que le président de la
république fasse des phrases on attend
qu'ils agissent
or aujourd'hui d'actions il n'en a pas
eu depuis deux ans et demi rien n'a été
fait il a reporté ce discours combien de
fois la première fois qu'il en a parlé
c'est en janvier 2018 puis en juin 2018
puis en janvier 2019
et tout ça pour arriver à dire est-ce
que c'est du communautarisme ou est-ce
que c'est du séparatisme
mais de qui se moque t'on est-ce que ce
président de la république est capable
de mettre en place une vraie politique
de sécurité pour lutter contre l'islam
politique pour lutter contre le
radicalisme pour lutter contre le
terrorisme commis en août ont depuis 30
ans crise en jacca parce que plusieurs
livres dénonce ce que l'on savait déjà
malheureusement depuis longtemps c'est
le rôle d'élus de gauche comme de droite
comme de droite qui pour des visées
électorales ont laissé prospérer ce
communautarisme islamistes nous nous
avons été où l'ours donné c'est vous le
déplorez nous avons été force de
proposition et nous regrettons
effectivement mais partout où il ya eu
ces accointances
bien évidemment qu'il doit avoir des
sanctions des sanctions de la plus
grande fermeté ce année inax et c'est
totalement inacceptable c'est à dire que
l'on met en danger la république c'est
en contre qui contre les maires les élus
qui ont laissé prospérer ce
communautarisme n'ont pas prospéré ceux
qui se sont prêtés à des accointances
effectivement avec avec avec ces gens
oui mais l'état aussi est complice il y
à un moment une responsabilité c'est
d'être de de mettre en place cette
politique de sécurité de se donner les
moyens de lutter contre ce que je disais
à l'instant sur ses 150 quartiers qui
sont tenus aux mains de deux radicaux de
radicaux qui en fait une idée en tête
déstabiliser la république et on ne peut
pas rester les bras ballants si c'est
l'absence de financement pourquoi le
lycée on n'interdit pas tout simplement
les moyens de financement savon et est
force de proposition en permanence sur
ce sujet il suffit de regarder les
propositions de loi qui ont été déposées
depuis trois ans par les républicains et
même avant puisque depuis le départ des
des attentats lorsque françois hollande
avait réuni pour la première fois les
présidents d'ego des différents groupes
parlementaires
nous nous avons été tout de suite force
de propositions à la fois sur les
djihadistes sur ces individus qui ont
porté les armes contre la france et qui
veulent revenir en france parce que la
france il a un is moment menés devant le
juge et il préfère revenir en france ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas acceptable
nous allons avoir 140 individus qui ont
été jugés pour des faits terroristes qui
vont être libérés dans les deux ans on
fait quoi on refuse la rétention
administrative mais c'est ça qu'on
attend du premier combat avec qui il
faut le mener cressanges rappaz est ce
que le cfcm le conseil français du culte
musulman est un partenaire aujourd'hui
crédible pour mener véritablement ce
combat contre la radicalisation
islamiste
d'abord il faut une volonté politique
cette volonté politique je ne les ai pas
senti depuis trois ans n'a compris ce
que glander le présentiel mené avec
avait avec des partenaires parce que le
conseil français du culte musulman est
un partenaire crédible
moi je pense que c'est d'abord à
l'assemblée nationale qu'on doit mener
ce débat c'est non répond ça veut dire
qu'il ne l'est pas mais c'est un débat
qui touche la république c'est les élus
du peuple qui doivent décider à quoi
sert l'assemblée si si si on n'a pas ce
débat et si on ne tranche pas à
l'assemblée nationale avec ceux qui sont
là pour porter la voix
peuple refusé d'avoir ce débat refusé
d'avoir des propositions mais quelle
indignité
vous savez quand on cède sur ce sur ce
terrain là soit en soutien
soit on est dans la lâche c'est très
important ce que vous dites ne pas céder
êtes-vous à droite bien au clair sur ce
sujet lorsque le président des
républicains à l'assemblée damien bad
lors de la ferme il a déclaré ceci ce
qu'a dit milla n'est pas acceptable
quand la liberté d'expression a détourné
pour créer de la haine anti religieuse
devienne une barrière à m il dit
exactement ce que vous venez de dénoncer
creissan jacques faty des louvoiements
sur la lane considère deux choses
c'était jusqu'à vous venez de chiens
c'est chacun peut exercer la religion de
son choix
mais chacun a la liberté de critiquer
toutes les religions et cette liberté on
ne peut pas être pas la même ligne que
les présenter à un public donné on va
terminer parce que on a entendu tout
heurt dans le journal de 8 heures c'est
important et vous vous affirmez votre
votre lutte contre la radicalisation
mais comment ne pas stigmatiser c'est le
moa et ne pas faire d'amalgamé aussi
c'est important de le dire entre les
islamistes et les musulmans la question
se pose
non parce que les islamistes radicaux
l'islam politique
ça n'est pas l'expression de la religion
musulmane et là il ya une vraie
différence devant nous sommes en face
d'un réseau de voyous de réseau de
terroristes et c'est à eux qu'il faut
s'en prendre
et c'est ce que je reproche au président
de la république de nous faire un cours
sur le séparatisme elle communautarisme
arrêtons de dire n'importe quoi
menon une vraie politique de sécurité
donnons nous les moyens d'aller sur ces
quartiers avec l'ensemble des forces de
police de justice avec les les douanes
et il faut je veux dire aujourd'hui le
qui ne prise en compte des forces
politiques qui ne l'ont pas pris en
compte pour le moment il faudrait que ce
soit un combat national évidemment
transporté dans tellement ce sujet est
important mais et nous nous avons
toujours été encore une fois force de
proposition texte de loi après texte de
loi que ce soit au sénat ou à
l'assemblée
les républicains ont toujours répondu
présent jamais nous n'avons et entend
était entendu par ceux pour mercy
cressanges en coop invité ce matin sur
europe 1